despite being one of the funniest people
on TV mayam bik's life outside of the
cameras has been marked by tragedy
mental health struggles and public
backlash The Big Bang Theory was
undoubtedly a great experience for miam
biic it not only made her a household
name around the country turning her into
a valuable and desirable television star
but it also made her a lot of money by
the time the show ended in 2019 she was
earning
$425,000 an episode however that doesn't
mean her time on the series was always
positive on her podc C mayami alic
breakdown the actors spoke about her
difficulty dealing with anxiety while
filming The Big Bang Theory despite
taking precautions and undergoing
treatments such as therapy the anxiety
that she suffered during shoots was
debilitating and often stopped her from
being able to perform she said I've had
this a handful of times when working on
Big Bang Theory when there was a certain
way they wanted a line delivered and I
was like oh okay I got that I'll do that
in the next take and I do it but it's
still not right and sometimes it's like
the audience isn't laughing you know
it's not funny 2012 was an important
year for miic she began to receive
widespread recognition for her portrayal
of Amy Farah Fowler on The Big Bang
Theory and was even nominated for an
Emmy Award for outstanding supporting
actress in a comedy series however it
was also a tougher in her personal life
with the actor being involved in a
serious car accident that left her with
a severely injured hand the incident
itself was significant enough to require
attendance by paramedics and
firefighters with bolic telling Vanity
Fair that it was a bad accident but it
could have been far worse her maed hand
didn't stop her from getting straight
back to work though and she returned to
the set of The Big Bang Theory as soon
as she was allowed to by medical staff
she said it's a testament to how much I
love my job because I went right back to
work Jim Parsons and Melissa Rous are my
buddies and I wanted to be with my
buddies you look beautiful of course I
do I'm a princess and this is my
tiara one specific moment from her time
on The Big Bang Theory stands out for
mayam biic is particularly painful to
film although Sheldon and Al character
Amy became one of television's most
popular couples the pair were certainly
unconventional and it was unclear
whether they would actually ever get
married that's exactly what happened at
the end of season 11 when the two tied
the knot after years of will they or
won't they story lines marriages are
supposed to be a celebration of love and
weddings a happy occasion what fans saw
on screen reflected that yet things were
not so thrilling behind the scenes
speaking in a blog post on grock Nation
the actor explained that posing as a
joyful bride was difficult because 5
years earlier she had separated from her
own husband she wrote as a divorced
woman it's hard to revisit that moment
in those decisions but it wasn't only
her own romantic history that made
shooting the wedding scene difficult
biik also revealed that she suffered
from several infections around the same
time that forced her to take a step back
from physical activity and work these
illnesses required antibiotic treatment
and ultimately led to her gaining weight
and feeling unattractive she said even
though everyone said I looked beautiful
I didn't feel completely
beautiful following her successful stint
on The Big Bang Theory mayam biic had a
starring role in the fox sitcom call me
cat based on a British comedy known as
Miranda it tells the story of a
39-year-old woman who quits teaching to
open up a cat cafe as she tries to find
happiness some of the other cast members
included Kyla Pratt as waitress Randy
and lesie Jordan as the head chef Phil
the 67-year-old Jordan died on October
24th 2022 according to reports he was on
his way to the set of the show for
filming when his car collided with a
building in Hollywood due to a medical
episode that was later described as a
sudden cardiac dysfunction his death
shocked both his fans and co-stars
speaking on the Jennifer Hudson show
biic confirmed that the cast and crew
for C me Cat found out about his death
while on the set you know it was a
sudden thing we were all at work and
waiting for him to show up at work so it
was very very very complicated the last
decade has brought the sexual abuse and
exploitation of women in Hollywood into
Focus shining a light on a massive
problem within the television and movie
Industries the issue came to the public
attention more prominently in 2017 when
the Harvey Weinstein Scandal exposed
just how widespread the problem was and
led to the me too movement remarking on
the disgraced producer in an oped
article for the New York Times mayam
biic confirmed that despite being
disgusted by his actions she wasn't
shocked to discover that a leading
Hollywood figure would behave in such a
way writing about her own experiences
the actor discussed seeing men in
Authority behave in similar ways feeling
that she had to protect herself from
sexual harassment in the workplace beic
detailed some of the ways that she
worked to ensure that she would not be
subjected to such Behavior she wrote I
still make choices every day as a
41-year-old actress that I think of as
self-protecting and wise I have decided
that my sexual self is best reserved for
private situations with those I am most
intimate with I dress modestly I don't
act flirtatiously with men as a policy
myam biic New York Times oped led to a
flurry of criticism from feminist groups
and others on social media the main
point of contention surrounded her
decision to avoid harassment by behaving
in a conservative manner or dressing
more modestly the actor was clearly
aware that the article may have been
controversial as she attempted to
mitigate what she was saying and make it
clear that she was still blaming men for
their behavior she wrote in a perfect
world women should be free to act
however they want but our world isn't
perfect nothing absolutely nothing
excuses men for assaulting or abusing
women but we can't be naive about the
culture we live in many people quickly
criticized beik pointing out that sexual
desire is not the only motive behind
this kind of harassment with Predators
also wanting power and control others
were offended that the actors seemed to
be implying that women had some
responsibility for the way abusers acted
just a few days later biik apologized
for the hurt she had caused with her
oped although this only happened after
initially saying that her words had been
Twisted beyond their intended meaning
the only people who are responsible is
the people the the Predators who are
committing those horrendous acts in 2021
mayam biic opened up for the first time
time about the fact that she has an
eating disorder talking to author Glenn
and Doyle on her Podcast May and beic
breakdown the actor spoke about her
experiences with anorexia and binge
eating inspired to talk about her eating
disorders by Doyle biik went into detail
about having to cope with overeating and
heavily restricting her diet she said
this is the first time I've ever talked
about it because people are like well
why are you so overweight well because
I'm a compulsive overeater in addition
to being an anorexic and restrictor
during the conversation it became clear
that the eating disorders may have
originated because beik faced a lot of
pressure about her weight due to her
acting career later in the discussion
bolik confirmed that she had been in
recovery for 2 years after seeking help
for the eating disorders that she
suffered with for years this included
cutting out caffeine and alcohol as she
attempted to improve her own mental
health Eating Disorders are not the only
mental health condition that mayic has
had to deal with throughout her life the
actor also has obsessive compulsive
disorder due to the fact that many
people feel embarrassed by OCD a large
proportion of people people with the
condition do not seek help or get any
form of treatment speaking about OCD on
myom bics breakdown she said that the
condition is not just about liking
things to be a certain way or being a
control freak but rather a way to
alleviate anxiety the compulsions are
typically actions that are done to
dispel the anxiety from the obsessions
these obsessions can be any form of
intrusive thought that typically
revolves around her questioning herself
and believing she has done something
wrong the actor also posted a video on
social media to address the intrusive
thoughts she has due to OCD and how they
affect her daily life before reaching
the age of 30 mayam be Alik married
businessman Mike Stone in 2003 the pair
met while studying at UCLA with Mike
even converting to Judaism so that they
could marry they were wed in Pas theena
with a Jewish ceremony and a Victorian
theme where the actor wore a vintage
wedding dress over the course of the
next decade Stone and beik had two sons
although the relationship eventually
broke down after 9 years of marriage
beik revealed that the pair had decided
to divorce after acknowledging the
sadness that divorce has on children
biic announced that the priority for the
former couple was their two sons with
that in mind the two have remained on
somewhat friendly terms in 2018 while
going through another painful breakup
biic outlined how she and stone had
spent Thanksgiving together for the sake
of the children it only strengthens my
kids' lives to have all of the people
they are related to together for
significant events the situation was
awkward however as Stone was living with
his new girlfriend at the time beik
wrote on grock Nation it was our first
time doing this kind of meal together
and I would be lying if I didn't say I
was nervous over the last few years
mayic has been outspoken about various
issues these have included everything
from mental health to family life with
the actor writing books running a Blog
and hosting a podcast to talk about
these topics while much of her content
has been well-received some of it has
caused controversy particularly her
views on parenting and child birth
speaking to Self Magazine biic discussed
the positive aspects of natural births
and noted that certain people sometimes
look down upon C-sections some of her
comments caused outrage meanwhile her
thoughts about home birth and hormonal
birth control also Drew heavy criticism
as they were not based on scientific
evidence or consensus also problematic
for many was bic's advocacy for
attachment parenting such as encouraging
parents to sleep in the same bed as
their children it's something which has
been said to lead to an increased risk
of death for babies mayic has also
proven controversial with her remarks
about vaccines before the covid-19
pandemic the actor revealed that her
family was non-vaccinating and that this
decision was made based on their own
research and discussions with her
pediatrician around the same time the
actor also supported the work of Dr Bob
Sears who argues that parents should not
be forced to vaccinate their children in
more recent years beic has taken a less
controversial approach to vaccines when
talking about them publicly Keen to
stressed that she was not an antivaxer
she confirmed that she would get the
covid-19 vaccine when it was available
and that her children would also be
vaccinated against the disease yet she
still seems to Harbor some skepticism of
vaccines in general telling Yahoo I have
a lot of questions about the vaccine
industry as do a lot of people I have a
lot of questions about the profits
involved mayic was raised in New York by
her Jewish parents and took an active
role in her religion while she was
initially part of the reformed Jew
movement the actor now considers herself
to be modern Orthodox Jewish it is this
strong connection to her religion that
meant that when her father died in 2015
she spent an entire year grieving him
she told Yahoo entertainment there's a
year of grieving in traditional Judaism
after that year it's kind of like a veil
lifts the grief didn't mean that she
entirely stopped working or doing other
things but it did dominate her thinking
during that time she added death is not
difficult but dying is there is nothing
harder than nursing your parent as they
die taking inspiration from these real
life events beic created the film as
they made us which starred Dustin
Hoffman Simon hellberg and Diana Agron
if you or anyone you know needs help
with an eating disorder visit the
national Eating Disorders association
website or contact Nita's life helpline
at 1800 931
2237 you can also receive 247 Crisis
Support via text send Neda to